in that previous episode Jackson Neville
aka mad Jack involved in several cases
of buying and selling stolen vehicles
this guy might have provided the killer
with a car ah it's pretty slim lead but
it's all I have right now scare me okay
we're partners right a police car will
be there diffusing oh my god the killer
has already called the police I think he
wants us to be a scapegoat we've got to
get that our shed now I'm taking your
home this is getting way too dangerous
no way we're partners remember we had oh
my gosh
stop the [ __ ] car
with him so much
do anything to hold him once again in my
arms know it hold hands
yeah good job scotch lv scotch I'll be
my knee welcome back to another exciting
episode of heavy rain we're coming close
to the ending of this I'm pretty nervous
I hope I don't [ __ ] up too much but yeah
let's check what we got in here hey
quacker would you do it in there that
guy looks friendly I'm not a cracker
nah man Jaden FBI can we talk for a
minute yeah all right I'm looking for
the owner of a blue Chevrolet Malibu 83
I don't give a damn how the car got here
whether you stole it or not I just want
to know who bought it from me sorry man
don't ring a bell uh-huh a real bad
memory
it scares me I'm scared UPS I can help
you to remember if we find out that you
sold the car to the man we're looking
for
uh-huh you're looking at some pretty
solid time inside jack oh that's not
gonna be good for your girl
oh no I'm trying to scare me with your
big talk leatherhead minimus all your
damn car take a walk
you're just jealous cuz I have hair and
you don't have any hoping in here that
okay
let's investigate I don't trust this guy
all right let's get on with evidence
that's my papa and you never said that
ha and what do we have what now why is
there blood here
I can think of a couple of reasons all
right let's follow where the blood is
going what is this what is that you know
she didn't
god
go up one of your cop buddies as
any questions but I don't have any
friends solder Robby's little mouth
I don't touch my nipples they're really
sensitive goddammit I gotta put oil on
your head Pig
I ain't got time to be playing around
with you let's just get you outta sight
it's no [ __ ]
I love life and my hair which you don't
have any on psycho haha
works every time I really I'm playing
with two seconds delay okay not two
seconds but at least like half a second
see I can't hit all of them ah yes axe
now yes [ __ ]
nah [ __ ] outta hard to log
what you got I haven't got up balls guys
go out walking around you're gonna tell
me about the man with the blue car
go [ __ ] yourself in the ass I don't even
think that's possible I never tried so I
don't know I'll write 11 hit you [ __ ]
yeah Boop [ __ ] dude big that's what
you get for humping barrels I'm gonna
blow a hole in your face huh all of it
your moon Skippy with the CSI every idea
gasoline you like fireworks Jack cuz I
bet them gas tanks are gonna blow up
real nice
maybe daddy don't mess with them fine
why mess with a barrel or rather I'll
say it was an accident cuz you won't
barely be able to talk well yeah yeah
yeah well yeah Jack queasy [ __ ]
you me I my crazy I'm a train come on
hurry about the guy you wanted me to get
rid of his dirty car ah a new one with
falls plates cash and huh the question
is kind said I was supposed to drop the
word to a guy named Paco down at the
Blue Lagoon the car was done ha ha no
we'll continue this discussion down at
the station you're under arrest
you have the right to remain silent
uh-huh thing ah
[ __ ]
anything you say can and will be hey you
look like you got a problem not a
problem I'll just have to get my trip
dog king ah what they let you dope heads
in the FBI now god bless america
I I want dad oh now I'm gonna give you a
little help with your good problem is
the five-o permanently Oh shed
oh [ __ ] May where's [ __ ] actually not a
bad idea
come on man we can't die now what are
you doing what are you doing what are
you doing stop stop that glove
compartment how's the music that's
lovely
haha huh
get the gun here get the gun here get
down here [ __ ]
and sure
oh [ __ ] we're coming close
did I die
nama dad oh thanks
get up Norman Jayden David with FBI come
on he's my favorite character he can't
die ah ah come on oh I made it anyway
apparently no more [ __ ] up here day I
know it's frustrating but it's more
frosting for me [ __ ]
Oh No
Oh
Serco oh I bet it doesn't know how
triangle no I hadn't heard so much ha
yes psycho now please make it please
Megan I'm gonna cry
yes ha no yes
ah come on
it's so evil did I die did I die what am
i I what was I supposed to do there
I started maybe it's a lie
I think you just knocked him out I don't
[ __ ] remember I gotta piss in his bed
so you think the origami killer killed
man Fred that makes sense
didn't want him spilling his guts to us
and you suspect Gordie Kramer right Oh
him or one of his men
Gordie has the time and the means not to
mention the [ __ ] up attitude to go
along with it I don't think his suspect
but he's a pretty guilty looking one but
is your files on the case yeah I've been
working on him for a couple years I
build up a mountain of paperwork
magazines about origami you think the
killer could have subscribed to one of
those if he was even remotely interested
in origami in the last 30 years his name
may be in there somewhere
trouble is is over 500 names it gets a
squat well we can I'm starving you have
anything to eat
Alice I'm no chef but I should be able
to make some scrambled eggs if you like
do you like scrambled eggs I'm soaking
white I need to warm up a little is it
okay if I take a shower
uh-huh be my guest go my bedroom it's
the next door I'll cook up the eggs
while you're under the shower all right
let's see how do you make scrambled eggs
I think you need eggs pretty sure yeah
we got eggs
stick them up I really hope it's not
dead really hope it's not dead
okay next step you take a plate I don't
know why oh okay
six Hana and then we crack it and
proofer this is actually a major impact
on the story if you fail up this omelet
or scramble eggs you're done for
and so I really gotta focus here oh [ __ ]
circle oh my god somebody's oh [ __ ] okay
let's put out the heat a little bit
circle in the other direction looks
pretty nice circle it some more because
we all have circles they're nice and
symmetric are let's wait a little bit
let's sneak on her in the shower
ah it's getting is it burning now I
should be ready by now all right fair
enough
that does not seem that good
oh man Bonjour ma nothing I took the
liberty of borrowing your bathrobe
voila looks better on you ha ha that's
kind of gross our genitals have been at
the same spot hey that almost looks good
enough to eat
what's that did the notebook I took for
Manfred's place
oh no according to this about 30 clients
bought spare parts for Royal machines in
the last 10 years the killer may be one
of them okay you know checking out the
alibi of 30 clients one by one that's a
lot of legwork
except that if we cross-check them on
the list of subscribers to origami
magazines you still got that right yeah
yeah Lauren wait okay
if the killer really used a royal
typewriter and if he subscribed to an
origami magazine his name should be on
both lists well Martin uh I mean that's
just an assumption but yeah I suppose
that's a pretty good assumption
his name is here somewhere help me we're
gonna find him all right
ah
come on you can go hello cleavage
yeah they got in the Calais the only guy
who's neighbors on both lists died when
he was ten what are you gonna do now
pick up his coffin make sure he's dead I
know it doesn't make any sense
unless the killer was only using his
name but why use the name of a kid who
died 30 years ago well that's what we
came to find out the name is John
Sheppard it should be on a grave around
here somewhere
all right you never give up do you
she's pretty good I mean she's a better
detective than he is I see
Daryl Allen Irish lad some kind of
system hayloft on it I found it hell
yeah
and there's our origami their origami
figures that's one hell of a coincidence
not really he's subscribe to origamis
these flowers are fresh
looks like someone's still tending the
gray Oh young and that one I do well you
know John Shepherd I've worked this
graveyard nearly all my life
uh-huh I remember what happened was in
77 October y'all we're finally gonna
find out huh
and then next episode if you enjoy this
guy remember ed today nothingexcept era
where me